Catherine from New Hampshire has a second question.
"What are students allowed to talk about related to homework questions
on the forums and outside to other students?"
This is a good question.
It's great to see all the discussion on the forums.
We do want students to be able to discuss questions on the forums to
provide hints if people get stuck.
What we don't want is for people to give out the actual answers,
and for you to submit homework when you didn't understand it
or solve it yourself.
I am on the forums often as many people who post on the forums know.
I often comment and answer questions.
I do look very closely at the questions related to the homework.
I remove anything that I deem over the line.
So far, I've been really impressed with students policing themselves and
restricting themselves to not giving away answers.
I've been really impressed.
Where I usually draw the line is step-by-step solutions--
start one, do this; step two, do this; or a general framework for how
to solve the problem.
The other thing that's over the line is posting code.
That just has the answer and says, "here's how you solve it."
That's no good.
In general, though, I don't really want to police the forum that strictly.
I want to encourage students to have a conversation, talk about the problems,
and help each other through them.
I think that really is the way you learn.
If the problem is hard, start getting some hints on how to get started,
but still work out the solution yourself.
Using the forums to do that is a great way to learn more
and to be able to understand the homework problems.